Muchos nos habéis pedido que saquemos un
vídeo hablando de Francia, uno de los países
más ricos y a la vez, con más problemas
económicos del mundo. A día de hoy, Francia
es la segunda potencia más grande de la Unión
Europea, pero esto podría durar mucho menos
de lo que alguno se imaginaría.
Su tasa de desempleo joven supera el 23%.
Esto no es mucho si lo comparamos con España
pero es que la situación española no es
ningún ejemplo.
Para que os hagáis una idea, hace 15 años,
el mundo entero compraba coches Renault y
teléfonos móviles de marca Alcatel. Hoy,
las exportaciones francesas han caído a menos
de la mitad. Sus empresas parecen incapaces
de competir con los gigantes de China, Corea
del Sur o incluso Estados Unidos y Alemania.
Y su gobierno está endeudado hasta las cejas.
Como os podéis imaginar, toda esta crisis
económica también tiene un reflejo en la
sociedad. Prueba de ello son estas últimas
elecciones de 2017. Ninguno de los candidatos
de los grandes partidos han conseguido pasar
a la segunda vuelta. La mayoría de los franceses
están hartos de su establishment político
y por eso han elegido a un presidente que quiere dar
un giro de 180º al sistema francés.
Y ahora la pregunta es ¿Cuáles son las
razones que han llevado a Francia a esta crisis?
Y lo que es más importante ¿Qué propone
Emmanuel Macron para solucionarlo?
Y lo que es más importante ¿Puede solucionarlo
Marine Le Pen?
Hoy vamos a responder a esta pregunta, pero
antes, vamos a ver un poco de historia.
Tras la Segunda Guerra Mundial, todos los
países de Europa estaban arruinados. Francia
entre ellos. La mitad del país estaba destruida
por los bombardeos, y eso incluye casas pero
también las fábricas y los cultivos. Por
suerte, el tío Sam estaba dispuesto a ayudar
generosamente. A fin de cuentas, a Estados
Unidos le interesaba que Europa se reconstruyera
rápidamente para tener un mercado donde vender
sus productos.
Y por eso, el llamado Plan Marshall supuso
una inyección de miles de millones de dólares
para que todos los países europeos se recuperasen.
¡Pero esperad un momento! Porque cada uno
de estos países utilizó esta financiación
de distintas formas. Por ejemplo, el Gobierno
Alemán desarrolló su propia filosofía política:
el liberalismo social, que combinaba el libre
mercado con las ayudas sociales. Es decir,
por un lado, el estado sacaba programas de
apoyo para los ciudadanos y toda clase de
subvenciones para que las empresas pudieran
reconstruirse. Pero por el otro, permitía
que esas empresas mantuvieras su titularidad privada y pudieran competir entre ellas.
El caso de Francia fue muy distinto. El entonces Presidente, el General
Charles de Gaulle,
no era un gran amigo de la empresa privada, y por eso su teoría política,
el llamado DIRIGISMO, era la opuesta a la
de los alemanes.
“Este gabinete no se dedica a hacer propuestas
sino a dar órdenes” –Charles de Gaulle
Así que de Gaulle utilizó todo ese dinero
que llegaba de Estados Unidos para nacionalizar
casi todas las grandes empresas francesas.
Fábricas siderúrgicas, sector eléctrico,
telefónico, etc… Incluso los gigantes del
automóvil como Renault, Peugeot, o Citroen,
tenían al Gobierno Francés como accionista
mayoritario.
Podríamos decir que  Charles de Gaulle representa todo lo contrario a lo que aplaudimos en VisualPolitik.
Sin embargo, es en esta época cuando Francia
entró en los llamados “Gloriosos 30”.
En sólo 3 décadas, los salarios de los franceses
se multiplicaron.
Y estas grandes empresas, apoyadas por el estado, se comían el mercado internacional.
Para que os hagáis una idea, mucho
antes de que las empresas americanas deslocalizaran
sus fábricas a China, Renault y Michelín
ya estaban montando factorías en España
donde los sueldos eran mucho más bajos.
Para que los que no lo sepáis, yo nací en
Valladolid. En mi ciudad hubo un antes y un
después desde que Renault abrió su planta.
Y de hecho, es de esta época de donde viene esa fascinación que siempre hemos tenido los españoles
por nuestros vecinos del norte que en los años
60 nos enseñaban a decir.
Pero seamos honestos, en aquella época todos
los demás países de Europa estaban creciendo
al mismo nivel. Pensadlo bien. Estamos hablando
de los años 60. Asia no tenía todavía
ninguna industria importante. Latinoamérica
sufría dictaduras de todos los colores.
Y los países del bloque soviético tampoco
producían productos de calidad que se pudieran
vender en el mercado internacional.
Sin embargo,
Francia tenía una importante tradición industrial,
una sociedad bien formada y sobretodo, seguridad
jurídica y un marco político estable para
las empresas.
¡No sólo eso! En 1958, todos estos países europeos recién reconstruídos gracias al Plan Marshal
deciden
formar una unión comercial, que sería el
germen de lo que hoy es la Unión Europea.
Y en este momento, Francia era el país con
más población de todos. No olvidéis que,
por aquel entonces, Alemania estaba partida
en dos. Eso significa que Francia tenía poder suficiente
como para negociar sus condiciones de entrada.
Ya os he dicho que Charles de Gaulle no era
muy amigo de la libre empresa. Tampoco del
libre comercio. Así que utilizó su posición
de fuerza para que Francia mantuviera su dominio
sobre ciertos sectores como la agricultura.
“Uno puede saltar y gritar Europa, Europa,
Europa! Pero no sirve para nada y tampoco
significa nada”
Si veis este vídeo desde España, seguro
que habéis oído hablar de la Política Agraria
Comunitaria. Una legislación que sirve para
evitar que en Europa compremos productos agrícolas
al tercer mundo ¡Pero no sólo eso! También
impone unas cuotas de producción DENTRO del
espacio europeo. Es decir, que un ganadero
polaco o español no puede producir y vender
toda la leche que quiera. Se tiene que ajustar
a unos máximos marcados por Bruselas. Pues
bien, eso es un invento de Francia. Y eso
explica cosas como esta:
“Con una valoración base de 70.400 millones
de euros, la producción agrícola francesa
lidera Europa”
De Gaulle se mantuvo en el poder durante décadas.
Y el resto de presidentes que ha tenido Francia
han mantenido este modelo de economía dirigista
al pie de la letra. A fin de cuentas, durante
los años 60 y 70, Francia estaba on fire.
Así que, si algo funciona ¿Para qué vas
a cambiarlo? Pues ahora mismo vamos a ver
por qué.
El problema surge cuando el resto del mundo
evoluciona más rápido que tu.
Y aquí llegamos a los años 80 y 90.
El muro
de Berlín cae, China comienza a abrirse al
mercado exterior y nuevos países como España o
Grecia entran en la Unión Europea. Y, por
supuesto, también quieren vender sus productos.
En otras palabras, a Francia le surgen competidores.
Y eso explica que noticias como esta sean
algo habitual en los informativos desde hace
décadas.
“Granjeros franceses furiosos han atacado
envíos de fruta y verdura española debido
a la crisis del E-COLI. Los productores españoles
han bajado los precios para cubrir sus pérdidas
y ahora son más baratos que sus homólogos
franceses”.
Y lo mismo ocurre con el resto de sectores.
Fijaros en esta gráfica de la balanza de
pagos de Francia.
Si os dais cuenta, veréis
que, a partir de los años 90, las exportaciones netas francesas
empiezan a caer paulatinamente. La tendencia es especialmente acusada a partir de la crisis
financiera.
¿Os acordáis de los teléfonos móviles
Alcatel? Cuando los móviles empezaron a masificarse,
Alcatel era uno de los gigantes del sector.
Hoy han desaparecido en en un mercado dominado
por empresas estadounidenses, chinas o surcoreanas.
Y este es un ejemplo más de esa pérdida
de innovación que sufre Francia.
¿Y cuál ha sido la respuesta de los distintos
gobiernos franceses durante todos
estos años? Pues mantener esa obsesión con proteger
a sus empresas del resto del mundo. Por ejemplo,
otros países como Suecia también tenían
a grandes compañías como, por ejemplo, la automovilista VOLVO. Sin embargo, cuando un grupo
de inversores chinos decidieron comprar esta
empresa, el Gobierno no se interpuso: tenían
muy claro que una cosa son los negocios y
otra la política.
No podemos decir lo mismo
de Francia. Mirad lo que ocurrió cuando PEPSI
quiso comprar la francesa DANONE en el año
2005.
“Jean Louis Borloo, el ministro de trabajo,
dijo que el Gobierno hará todo lo que pueda
para evitar la compra y Thierry Breton, ministro
de finanzas, defendió que hay que proteger
Danone”
Sin embargo, hay cosas que no cambian en Francia.
Su gasto público sigue siendo el más alto
de toda la Unión Europea. Muy por encima,
incluso, de los países nórdicos. El estado
francés emplea a más funcionarios que ningún
otro país europeo. Y, además, les paga
bastante mejor que lo habitual en las empresas privadas.
En otras palabras: Francia ingresa cada día
menos dinero pero continúa gastando al mismo
nivel que en los años gloriosos. Eso explica
que su deuda pública esté creciendo hasta
niveles completamente insostenibles.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque ahora es
cuando parece que las cosas pueden cambiar!
Ya lo sabemos: una cosa es lo que un político
promete en campaña electoral y otra muy distinta
lo que hace una vez llega al gobierno. Pero
a Emmanuel Macron le tenemos que reconocer
una cosa: su programa electoral era una ruptura
absoluta con este dirigismo francés. Todos
los analistas han tildado a este hombre como
un político moderado y continuista pero…
¿Realmente lo es?
Lo cierto es que tiene propuestas que nunca
se habían oído antes en ningún otro presidente
francés, ni de izquierdas ni de derechas.
Queremos abrir la competencia en los servicios y en sectores como bienes de consumo y transportes.
Para que os hagáis una idea, en una campaña
electoral marcada por el populismo de Le Pen,
Macron propone prejubilar a más de 120.000
funcionarios del estado. Y sí, muchos pensaréis
que esto es una barbaridad. Pero tenemos que
reconocerle una cosa: HONESTIDAD. Es decir,
cualquier otro político enmascara sus propuestas
más impopulares con términos muy genéricos
como “optimización del gasto” o “reducción
de la deuda”.
Macron, sin embargo, se ha
ganado la confianza de los votantes haciendo
lo opuesto a lo que se supone que debe hacer
un candidato. En su programa también asegura
que no va a reducir la edad de jubilación.
En otras palabras, tiene un plan muy claro
para reducir el gasto público.
Por otra parte, Macrón combina estos recortes
con una bajada general de impuestos y una
política de ayudas a las empresas pequeñas.
En sus propias palabras, Macron quiere sustituir
el modelo económico dirigista por un sistema
más parecido al de los países nórdicos o Alemania, donde
el estado garantiza servicios sociales pero
no interviene en la economía privada.
Es decir, separación entre negocios y política.
Pero ahora os preguntaréis… aunque haya
ganado las elecciones ¿Tiene capacidad real
para llevar a cabo estas propuestas? En Francia,
la figura del presidente tiene más poder
que en otros países. Pero aún así, cualquier
ley que quisiera sacar Macron, tendría que
pasar por el parlalmento francés ¿Y quién
domina ese parlamento?
Lo cierto es que no lo sabremos hasta este
verano. Más concretamente en JUNIO de 2017,
los franceses volverán a las urnas, esta
vez para votar al poder legislativo.
y ahí, el partido de Marine Le Pen tiene nuevamente
muchas posibilidades de ser la fuerza mayoritaria
frente al aperturismo de Macron. Pero… ¿Qué
propone la extrema derecha francesa? Haced
click aquí para ver el vídeo en el que os
contamos la historia de el clan Le Pen. Una
historia que incluye luchas familiares, tramas de poder y
hasta conejitas de playboy.
Pero ahora la pregunta es ¿Realmente creéis
que esta revolución silenciosa de Macrón
puede sacar a Francia del atolladero? ¿Creéis
que el estancamiento de Francia tiene algún
remedio? Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta
en los comentarios.
Pero esperad un momento! Estos acordes tan
melódicos y hermosos que están sonando,
son la música de TASMANIA, que ya sabéis
que es un grupo de grunge de Alicante, en
España, que son grandes amigos de este canal.
Y necesitan nuestra ayuda. Están participando
en un concurso para poder tocar en el SPRING
Festival junto a otras bandas como Rock of
Lesbian. Y para ganar, necesitan conseguir
más de 1000 likes en una fotografía. Así
que, por favor, entrad en el enlace que os
he dejado en la descripción y dadle a LIKE
a su foto. Que no se diga que en VisualPolitik
no apoyamos a los grupos de música que están
empezando.
Y también os tenemos que dar las gracias
a todos los que nos hacéis donaciones a través
de nuestra cuenta de PayPal. Nunca os hemos
pedido que lo hagáis pero muchos estáis
colaborando voluntariamente con VisualPolitik
y eso nos está ayudando a sacar este proyecto
adelante y a sacar nuevas sorpresas que os
contaremos pronto.
Así que muchas gracias porque todos vosotros lo hacéis posible. .
Y si sois nuevos y esta es la primera vez que entráis en el canal suscribiros para no perderos ninguna actualización.
Si os ha gustado el vídeo, dadle a LIKE y
nos vemos en el próximo. Un abrazo y hasta
pronto!